you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is around
11:00 game from the 2016 Tata Steel
chess tournament masters section between
Magnus Carlsen playing on the white end
and Howie fan these two played for the
first time in last year's taught to
steel tournament where Carlsen had the
white pieces he's playing as white again
in this one let's see how things would
play out
efore e5 Knight f3 Knight f6 the
Petrov's defense we have the nimzowitsch
attack with Knight c3 don't be misled by
the term attack we have anything but
that in this game things are pretty
uneventful in the opening and middle
game several piece exchanges soon occur
and yeah we have an ending in this one
soon coming about where it's Queen and
Bishop versus Queen and Bishop and
shortly thereafter a King and pawn
ending alone that part of the game is
the part that I found interesting Knight
takes D takes minor pieces out getting
castle at white goes Queen side black
prepares queenside castle b3 h3 to grab
some King side space and complete
development black goes Queen side if
black is going king side this is a much
different ball game G for a v g5 each
side going after the Kings looking to
open files against the enemy King timing
will be a great factor not the case here
we're not attacking one another's King
queenside castle g4 h6 rules out g5 if
g5 is played this is a favorable
exchange for white the H pawn has been
exchanged for the extremely valuable G
pawn white now has split pawns Bishop g2
King be a white centralizes so too does
black King be too they six and now light
prepares to double on the e-file the
only open file and when that is the case
when there is only one open file it's
not uncommon for both sets of rooks to
be exchanged we soon have both rooks
exchanged in this one Queen c7 this
seems a little bit awkward to place the
Queen opposite the rook but this is only
temporary
the Queen's destination is f8 and what
she is basically doing what the Queen is
doing here is getting out of the way of
the light square bishop who had no good
moves from at this point here so Queen
is getting out of the bishops way so he
can move and then the rooks you kind of
be offset white doubles Queen of fate
lady for several exchanges now I think
takes Bishop takes Bishop takes how to
recapture on d4 Queen takes you could go
with the pawn you're not going to see a
great shift in the evaluation and this
is something I'd like to draw just a
little bit of attention to this capture
because I believe many would just go
with the pond seeing this is a moment to
you know this is my moment to undal my
pawns let's go for Queen takes is a move
that I like I like having these ponds
close to the King with the Queen still
on the board like this this
configuration of ponds and it doesn't
show up in this ending but it's
worthwhile to note it could very well
end up in plenty of other and game
situations where you're still working
each side is still working with a queen
this configuration of pawns the b3 c3 in
situ structure
for the white king is an excellent
pocket to combat a possible perpetual
check by black the pun stops any checks
along the file the c-pawn is responsible
for stopping the diagonal checks and the
c-pawn stops rank checks compare this
with black and their pawn structure they
don't have that configuration we could
one day suppose these guys are no longer
around on the back rank we could see the
Queen bouncing back and forth on AJ and
d4 to land a perpetual check to the king
something worthwhile to note this is an
asset in a queen ending this type of
pocket for the white king it is not the
same if this pawn is here because he
requires now the defense of a piece
other than the king anyhow it's again
it's not something that shows up in this
game this idea of a perpetual check but
it's worthwhile to note okay Bishop d7
like grab some King side space rooks are
now exchanged and there's really not
there hasn't been much going on in this
game it's pretty even when I bring up
the graph I'll show you it it'll be
saying that it's ever so slight
advantage but it could just as well be
saying 0 for an evaluation there isn't
there isn't much to do these next couple
of moves are examples of just one move
threats threatening me in one these one
move threats are just not enough they're
easily addressed it's when there are two
weaknesses and if white is able to
pinpoint both weaknesses in one move
that could be difficult to defend but
these one move threats are again easily
addressed
so c6 defends bishop f1 threatens to
take upon since the b-pawn is pinned
black it side the pin and just kind of
fast-forwarding some this is really all
we have are these one move threats Queen
attacks the pawn counter-attack against
the bishop the queen is now here to
secure these two points what are the
only other sensitive points it's d6 the
King will easily cover that bishops are
now off and yeah these are two
vulnerable points the King can watch
over here the Queen has the other two c4
hang up check and soon we have with this
one the Queen's being exchanged right
here and this is the big moment in the
game extremely important moment for
black blacks on move here move 45 up
into this point dead even just call it
this next move there's an issue however
there are 11 legal moves for black here
only one of them will hold this ending
to a drop I wonder if you can spot it
what would you do in this position as
black if you'd like to go ahead spend
some time with this one working it out
try and find the drawing idea for black
in this King and pawn ending
okay the drawing idea is a five this is
a must move this was not played in the
game the move played was h5 and this
allows white to win if I'm to just show
the graph here I'll get an idea of how
things played out all the way up until
move 45 again it'll be showing a slight
advantage but this is nothing slight you
know nothing significant I should say up
until this point King takes c3 point 401
this is a drop into this point an issue
with the next move
h5 clearly let's see how things played
out after h5 how did white enter well
how did white make progress he entered
by way of B for a 5 and he really wants
to get to B 6 can he get there yes
because he has these Tempe and reserve
he can eventually force black into Zook
swung into a position where he kind of
has to concede something he has to give
ground black has to give up control of
b6 and this is a big deal if the black
if the White King could post up here
he's exerting pressure on both black
pawns and tied in with this b5 break
black has to give up both the a and C
pawn so from here we had h4 King goes
back already
if d4 is played well white still has
another move here b4 and then the King
has to go back so in the game black just
went back right away
King b6 and now this is the idea b5
takes sakes takes again king c7 and
after c3 black resigned there's nothing
to do here superior
position what soon to happen is the C
and B pond will be exchanged and then Y
could simply walk along the fifth-ranked
and pick up all the other black pawns
so if hos King d7 King b6 King c8 c6
take stakes and then you get the idea
there might have been one cute finish if
things played out if they took it
further we could have had a an
interesting ending where after c6 King
ba this is still winning for white C
takes B still winning black King can't
move there's only one legal move with d4
if you take its stalemate but you could
actually push and allow block to Queen
first but in the end you're mating with
a pawn this did not happen again
after c3 black resigned so what was the
drawing idea it was a five but why why
does a5 draw and nothing else
drop well what's the trick with this a 5
first off it stops king before but
really the deeper idea and the main idea
here with a5 is to stop the king from
entering on B 6 this is what a 5
prevents life from doing you cannot get
your King to be 6 if you can't get to b6
you're not winning this game the only
other key Square b6 is a key square it's
a potential entry point for the White
King so too is e5 if white ever tries to
get to e5 well that's easily prevented
by King e6 and notice that black has two
squares that he can continually move to
he could bounce back and forth on e6 and
f6 and what is he doing
constantly watching over the key square
e 5 after a 5 V 4 suppose B 4 this is
the idea by black keep the pawn on a5
sitting h5 takes if you're not
taking the pawn and playing here you're
not making any progress on this side of
the board now and the only key square to
watch over is e5 and that's easily
guarded if we know if we take stock of
all the squares the black pawns control
b4 c4 c4 d5 the white king can never go
here
that's another square another one this
is the only entry and again it's easily
guarded so b5 doesn't do anything the
only thing to test out is this capture
after let's say h4 King b4 King c7 a6 is
the only trying to open up the a5 square
but notice something after a six black
replies blacks reply I should say does
two things one captures upon okay we see
that but two it opens up a new square
for the black King b7
so after a5 there's King b7 and what has
what has transpired here well a new with
this new square opened up black has
similar to this idea over here when
trying to watch over the e5 square black
has two squares he can move back and
forth to and always be controlling the
key square b6 just as he was doing over
here when the White King tries to enter
the e5 square the King can continually
move there's endless endless tempe an
infinite amount of tempe that the king
could use and you're always watching
these key squares and this is this is
really the trick here with this a5 idea
you know if white is going to enter in
this direction they're going to have to
take and then eventually do this a six
push to open up the a5 square but you
open up the a5 square for the King after
B takes a there's now a new square
opened up for the black King what
happened in the game we got to this
point
here where there is unfortunately for
black not to squares for the King to
continually bounced back and forth to to
watch over b6 that's the big trick here
this a five idea eventually the tempos
are all exhausted by black and he has to
concede ground he has to give up the b6
square he's in Zook swung a five idea
eliminates this this little trick here
it doesn't allow white to place black in
Zook swung playing this a5 idea these
end games are tricky King and pawn
endings there's a lot of calculation
needed you have to be extremely careful
with how you use your your Tempe and one
wrong slip as we saw in this one playing
h5 instead of a five and the game was
thrown away anyhow I hope you found well
not the opening or middle game but this
King and pawn ending instructive and as
usual if you have any comments you'd
like to leave in the comments section
below feel free to do that and I hope
you got something out of this video
that's all for now take care bye
you